you know I'm a big fan of Tommy tongs
you know self thinking robots running
around doing chores and all that stuff
of course if they have the ability to
think for themselves probably getting
into some trouble yeah we'll worry about
that later anyhow entities are a
fantastic concept attaching logic to
units is the backbone of how your
simulation is going to exist now don't
get too far down the rabbit hole here
entities bridge the line between design
and code so at every step of the way
when you add features you're going to
have to negotiate between how much of
the control is on the designer side and
on the programmer side so make sure when
you're designing your framework keep
both parties involved